Kelly would you have for breakfast?
I ate 20 dwarves while doing a handstand on the carpet.
It's a key that carpet,
this attitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living this year.
Podcast is brought to you by Mizzen and main.
Don't worry about the spelling.
All you need to do is this.
I have organized my entire life around avoiding fancy shirts because you have to
iron them.
You sweat through them,
they smell really easily.
They're a pain in the ass.
Mizzen and main has given me the only shirt that I need.
And what I mean by that and Kelly Starr at loves the shirts as well,
is that you can trick people.
They look really fancy so you can take them out to nice dinners,
whatever,
but they're made from athletics,
sweat wicking material.
So you can throw this thing into your luggage in a heap or on your kitchen table
like I did recently and then pull it out,
throw it on with no ironing,
no steaming,
no nothing.
Walk out and you could probably wear this thing for a week straight or make it
your only dress shirt and take it on trips for weeks at a time.
Never wash it.
It will not smell.
You will not sweat through it.
You got to check these things out.
So go to four hour workweek.com all spelled out,
four hour work week.com forward slash shirts and if you order one of their dress
shirts in the next week,
you will get a Henley shirt for free.
That's worth about 60 bucks.
So put them both in the cart.
Use the code Tim,
Tim,
and you'll get the Henley shirt for free.
Check it out.
Four hour workweek.com forward slash shirts and you'll see some of my favorite
gear,
including the one shirt that I've been traveling with.
The Tim Ferriss show is also brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is your one stop shop for anything.
Graphic design related.
You need a logo,
you need a website,
you need a business card or anything else.
You get an original design from designers around the world who submit drafts for
you to review,
you are happy or you get your money back.
And I have used 99 designs for book cover ideas for the four hour body,
which went to Number One New York Times for banner ads and you can check out
some of my actual competitions@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim you can
also get a free $99 upgrade if you want to give it a shot.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I am thrilled to be bringing you yet another example of worldclass performance
and of course in the Tim Ferriss show,
what I attempt to do is deconstruct those performers to give you the tools and
tricks that you can use and whether those people be from the worlds of finance,
say investors like billionaire Peter Teal,
celebrity like Arnold Schwartzenegger or sports,
and this is going to focus on the one thing besides politics and religion,
the get Americans all hot and bothered,
and that is crossfit.
We will delve into the good,
the bad,
and the ugly of all things crossfit.
We will answer many,
many questions including what are the three most dangerous exercises in crossfit
gyms?
Generally speaking,
what are the most common nutritional mistakes in crossfit?
What do elite crossfit athletes do differently than the rest?
For example,
what do rich Froning and Jason Khalifa do for warmups?
Is the crossfit games really crossfit and what is the future of crossfit the man
to answer all of this and much more as Kelly Starr ret,
he's trained crossfit athletes for more than 130,000 hours and 10 years at San
Francisco.
Crossfit,
which was one of the very first 50 crossfit affiliates in the world.
There are now more than 10,000.
His clients include Olympic gold medalist,
Tour de France,
cyclists world and national record holders and Olympic weightlifting and power
lifting,
crossfit games,
metalists ballet dancers,
elite military,
on and on and on.
This is going to go very,
very deep.
It involves significantly less alcohol than the last long conversation I had
with Kelly,
uh,
which is also included in the blog
post@fourhourworkweekdotcomforwardslashpodcastwhereyoucanfindshownotesandotherthingsforourworkweek.com
forward slash podcast and without further ado,
enjoy,
discuss,
debate,
yell and scream.
Here you are.
Kelly started
Sir Kelly.
Welcome back to the shell.
Oh,
thanks for having me.
Thank you.
A little more lucid this time.
Perhaps little lucid,
little less alcohol,
a little more caffeine.
Whatever you gave me here.
I mistakenly thought it was one cup of coffee and you're like it strong.
I was on the phone and I was like,
I don't worry.
Yes,
strong fucking strong coffee.
What?
I think it's supposed to be diluted at like eight to one,
but it's fine.
I'm sure it'll be fine.
So we are here at San Francisco crossfit and you have quite an anniversary,
I suppose you could call it.
You've spent 10 years in this world called crossfit.
Yeah,
this is,
this year now is 10 full years.
So I want to dig into this because we've known each other for quite awhile and
to perhaps lead off for people who may not be familiar with this world or have
heard the word a million times but don't know what it really means for you.
What is crossfit or how do you define crossfit?
You know there,
there's the official definition of trying to get people to work at higher
intensity in movements that replicate the movements that we see in life.
It looks like squatting and dead lifting and pushing and pulling and running.
And if you had to sort of mash up the tenants of gymnastics,
Olympic lifting,
power lifting and all the,
the aerobics responsibilities also that come along with that.
That's what the programming looks like,
but that's not what it is for me now,
10 years I've been,
I mean we estimate even in our gym here,
we've doing it for nine plus years.
We've done maybe 130,000 athlete hours here,
which is a lot of pattern recognition.
That's a lot of people going up and down,
squatting,
moving and what we've come to,
I've really come to understand this mean this is my own interpretation is
basically saying,
we've figured out now here are all the things that a human should be responsible
to be able to do.
You know?
Can you put your arms over your head?
Yes or no?
Well,
can you do that in a handstand?
Can do that with a Dumbbell,
can do that with a Kettlebell and new with the barbell.
Can you,
can you go from ground to overhead to do that?
Can you press overhead?
What ends up happening then is we've been able to winnow down to say,
here are the positions,
the archetypal shapes that are represented in every sport and every shit
situation,
every,
every position.
But in the gym I can say,
do you have this position?
Yes or no?
And then I can say,
Oh,
you do.
Well,
let me challenge it.
And the obvious one for the gym,
for most people is,
you know,
is,
is load.
Let's make it heavier.
And you know,
cause you've come out of a serious drink conditioning background in the past and
powerlifting that along time ago,
our answer to everything was,
oh,
just get stronger.
You know,
he's got glute weakness.
I'm like,
seriously?
I mean that guy deadlift 700 you think his glutes are weak or she plays in the
NFL.
You know what I mean?
Like people are ridiculous.
It's not a weakness problem.
And what I found for a long time was that we were throwing bigger and bigger
engines onto cars that couldn't handle it.
Right?
Well,
how much do I need to squat if I'm a runner?
400500600 guys like Pawel where like you can double body weight back squat,
you're probably good enough to 60 you're excuse from skidding and he's stronger.
Right?
I know Dan John was like,
Hey,
you should front squat.
You know,
a long time ago Greg Glassman was like,
you look at the overhead squat versus your front squat.
Just presuppose that you can do those two movements.
Right?
Right.
And then look at the difference between there.
And that's a pretty good indicator of how robust your spine is and how good your
shoulders are.
So we've gotten,
now we can start asking a little bit different question besides,
is it because what we,
what we evaluated was will I put more weight on the bar so it must be better,
right?
But now we can say,
Hey,
what about if I have you run around the building and you start breathing hard
and then show me how strong you are.
Show me how that position was.
Oh,
okay.
So now I can challenge your position with cardio-respiratory demand.
And boy,
that starts to look a lot like sport.
Huh?
Like fighting looks like skiing at the bottom of a bump run or running all the
way down and having to cut or you know what I mean?
They'll actually starts to feel like sport.
What happens if I start to burn or I'm fatiguing metabolic demand?
What happens if I add speed?
I make a lot of errors.
If I go fast,
what happens if I'm competing like you and I just decided right now we're going
to go have a pushup contest.
Whether you are the world champion and pushups or not,
a little bit of your back of your brain starts to freak out because it's on the
spot.
So we had the psychological pressure.
What happens if I make you change mechanics?
And so this is a bunch of block practice.
Instead of doing a hundred swings,
we're going to do a burpee than to a Calabasas.
So suddenly I can change the motor programming.
And what we found,
and my,
this is my own language around this,
is that all of those things are really deficient of intensity,
metabolic load,
right?
Car,
respiratory demand,
load speed.
The other aspects are the aspects of the training that are the sort of
intellectual piece around sort of programming in the training.
But my estimation is the people who can maintain the best positions are the best
athletes and remain the most robust and have the biggest work capacities.
And as a side effect,
because we teach all these principles can apply them to things that matter,
like life and sport,
not just more exercising.
No,
it's a,
I was having a conversation with,
uh,
you mentioned Paul and uh,
he's,
he is a tendency for very short answers,
which is fun to listen to,
his great voice too,
for the short answers.
But somebody asked him,
uh,
for basic advice related to endurance and he said,
fix your posture,
work on your posture.
Uh,
whether that is,
you know,
running posture,
standing posture,
sitting posture,
et cetera.
And what I'd love to ask you is,
if you look at the crossfit community as a whole,
there's so many gyms,
so many boxes,
uh,
what are problems that are very often not being addressed?
So people come in,
they jumped straight into,
you know,
the workout of the day or,
or,
or metabolic conditioning.
Um,
what are some common mistakes of whether it be crossfit instructors or trainees
where they come out six months later and from your eye you're like,
ab and C has not been sure.
Well,
I will correct and just play the devil's advocate around the statement because
my experience is honestly now,
Ben,
no one just jumps right into a gym anymore.
You can see on the Internet and go explore on your own garage.
But I think about a hundred percent of the gyms I run into have some sort of,
holy crap,
you don't know how to move.
You may have a big engine,
but you don't have any exposure to this.
Like our cyclists are the worst.
They come in with the most like robust aerobic engine.
They generate huge amounts of concentric forests have no eccentric control at
all.
Right?
So it means they can't lengthen underload basically.
Right.
And then those people listening who are not in the gym much.
If you're in a squat position and you move up into a standing position,
you can think of that as concentric doing the reverse east centric where you're,
you're,
you're lengthening.
So what we saw was that people were coming in relatively aerobic fed.
I mean,
people aren't slouches anymore.
There really aren't.
They're exposed,
they're doing intervals that,
I mean the Internet has blown people's,
I think general conditioning now much higher.
Like for example,
and I'll come back to the question,
but for example,
you know the,
the crossfit unofficial crossfit mascot,
everyone loves the show is pukey right?
Pukey the clown.
I haven't seen someone vomit in a crossfit in eight years.
I used to happen all the time.
Like people used to come in and do a workout and vomit because technically
there's an area in the back of your brain stem called the area post Irma.
It's samples your blood circulation.
Right?
And what ends up happening is people are generally so much lactic acid that
their brain was like,
you've poisoned yourself but activated your vom mission center.
That's the mechanism for vomiting from workouts.
That doesn't happen anymore because people's conditioning,
whether you're at soul cycle,
you'd go to soul cycle,
blow your brains up on a bike,
you're going to be d like you protect it,
not from move Mary centric love,
but like you will be able to buffer some lactic acid,
right?
So we've seen,
I seen the general fitness go up,
but what has happened now is that people have said,
okay,
look,
you can't just come in here and train because you're going to wreck yourself and
more important,
you're not going to understand what is we're trying to do,
which is here are the fundamental movements that are the sort of,
um,
sort of signature positions of the crossfit method.
And you don't know any of them,
right?
So we,
we,
we forced people to come in and the mistake is as a coach that I need to get
people moving.
And this is why if you go to a crossfit level one seminar,
they are going to teach you.
And they're really excellent,
excellent coaches,
very thoughtful,
very,
the,
the course has evolved in 10 years.
A ton.
We've become more sophisticated 10 years,
but we teach you with really low loads,
I.
E.
A PVC pipe or medicine ball because I've never seen anyone die from those
things.
But the ego gets involved and pretty soon there's a barbell in it and you can
still see people performing a tremendous amount of work in bad positions.
And what ends up happening is as we get people in,
we have to give them a little taste of the intensity.
And we do that with the rowing machine and some burpees,
right?
We get,
we get them saying,
hey,
I need to show you what happens when you start reading hard.
But then,
and we ended up making I think a set of decisions about getting people moving,
right?
Because if you,
if your mind mom,
maybe you don't have the ankle range of motion,
you have an artificial hip.
The most important thing is that we start squatting,
right?
And I have a lot of ways of making that difficult.
Oh,
we're going to be on this,
this air dyne and we're going to sprint a little bit and then come back and air
squat.
For me,
like that's enough for a lot of people.
The problem is,
and I might turn your feet out and I might be okay with you rounding your back a
little bit,
doesn't have to be perfect,
but now at least you're squatting.
We can have a conversation about what's next,
right?
I can make errors.
The problem is we start loading this inefficient,
this compromise movement because we said,
hey,
the first thing is let's get moving.
Now what and what is we need to continue to refine the mechanic for life and
that's the biggest mistake.
I think people don't understand that.
They're like,
well,
they're squatting up and down.
Now find the mechanic meaning the movement,
the principles behind the move,
right?
Right.
And it's all there for us.
It has always been there for us.
Hey,
limit motion of your spine.
Underload everyone agrees.
And yet when I take the average person off the street and just have them squat
very fast,
I see a ton.
I had a young NFL prospect and today,
right,
getting some advice about his knees going to go to the combine.
I asked him,
just do an air squat and the amount of reversal in his spine,
he literally rounded into a dumped like dog taking a poop position.
And he had massive fins in the middle of his back where his musculature has
overdeveloped from him,
basically rounding underneath.
And I was like,
um,
so that's not really good.
Let's do less of that.
And he's like,
what?
Wha what are you talking about?
Like he couldn't even identify that this thing was going on.
Right.
And you know,
from the physical therapy side of things,
from the sports performance side,
the highest level form on these issues that I hammer on and hammer people on are
the limiting factors to you getting,
stopping injured.
And there are the limiting factors to you being the best in the world and
winning a gold medal.
I mean,
these little details.
And so we should be constantly refining technique to express what is full
physiology.
So,
for example,
um,
there was,
uh,
you know,
one of the things,
there's so many voices and fitness now and so when people come in,
but like someone basically,
do you know what apologetics is like?
That's,
I get the first part,
not the plural apologetics is basically in religion where people come around and
explain a phenomenon in terms of the dogma that this is what that meant now.
Right?
Then they,
it's because a lot of it was allegory and metaphor and lesson,
right?
In science fiction,
apologetics means you can explain any technology away based on some other thing.
Well,
I see apologetics happen in human physiology.
Oh,
the reason you can't squat all the way down is your hip structure,
right?
Oh,
well some people don't just have long Femur,
so they can't take a poo in the woods.
It's Squallo down.
And I'm like,
what are you talking about?
The issue is that people we haven't making,
giving people clear benchmarks about what is normal and what is this normal,
right.
Cook and those guys cook and Burton,
the functional movement screen have tried to establish baselines for
performance,
but those don't even go all the way to show me that you have full range of
motion,
your ankles like you.
One of the secrets I don't think people understand is that you are,
you have good positions and those positions have protected you for a long time,
right?
You have a,
you can squat with your feet together,
ankles together all the way down full hip function for ankle function,
but people are coming into the gym basically as demi human,
they have big Rubik engines because that's what someone said they should do,
but they don't have even like 50% of the ranges of motion it should have and
they don't even have the motor control to be able to start to express this
stuff.
You know,
what is it?
If you want the great tranquility,
be willing to sweat the white hot beads,
right?
I mean Olympic lifters got it right?
And you can see why they lumped with Virgil like what the hell?
Why aren't you Olympic lifting?
You can't even put your arms over your head.
You know what I mean?
And the Olympic lifting demands that we have basic capacities and all of these
shapes.
The only thing that's missing is the bench press shape.
But guess what?
Olympic lifters do some bench pressing.
You know what I mean?
So they figured it out.
It's a lot easier to go that direction.
You know they're round.
Right.
And that's right.
And so it's interesting,
you know,
I think that what we're,
what we have not done a good job of is showing people how far away from normal
they are.
Right.
We,
you'd have no,
I'm like you should be able to keep your back flat and leg straight and hinge
over and pick up a barbell.
And I bet,
I know you can do it cause I've seen you do it.
But I bet that 95% of the people the street are stiff,
don't have the motor control,
tight hips,
whatever.
It doesn't matter.
It's not an indictment on their lifestyle and an that we don't understand what
could function is.
And the training we've been doing for the last 50 years has not necessarily
heightened that.
Now there are populations,
the Jujitsu guys have been on this a long time,
right?
That you have to have these good positions there.
The requisites are is the size of camel flexors.
It's true cause a little low back soreness otherwise besides that.
But what you're seeing is a lot of people have worked this out many,
many,
many times.
We haven't applied it to sort of the rigor of modern humans.
And that means modern strengthen conditioning.
And we haven't couched it in the terms.
So when people walk into the gym,
you know it is,
I don't think people realize as a coach it is an enormous fucking challenge to
say,
oh by the way,
you have no understanding of how you move.
And if I make you breathe a little bit hard,
if you throw it away and you move like crap and by the way you eat like an
asshole and you don't sleep.
And what are we going to do in this hour?
We have to start a conversation.
So for me,
there's this line of,
well,
we've got to get people in the door and we got to get them started.
Right?
But that's not the end of the conversation,
you know?
Yeah.
You can squat with your feet turned out like ducks.
You totally can.
You can set a world record in powerlifting like that,
but you know what you can't do,
you can't run.
You can't jump and land.
You can't cut.
I mean,
it really caused all these problems.
I see it.
And I also see people losing performance that way.
So the question remains this dichotomy,
then his chair,
my feet are turned out because that allows me to squat all the way down.
Great.
That's a beginning of a conversation.
But the optimal position is the position that allows me to take my fitness and
now transplant that into motor patterns instead of just saying,
well,
you're really fit now,
so you're protected now.
And he said,
well,
I've practiced these shapes and this pattern and the,
the theory and the principal and I can then apply that to whatever I'm doing.
And that's what's missing from the gym.
So this is,
uh,
this is a really fascinating topic for me.
The,
the gym to sport transition huge and whether that is a worthwhile goal.
Also,
uh,
for me,
just as a side note,
I mean,
I've been spending time exploring,
just chanced upon meeting the cofounder of Acro Yoga and I'd never had much
interest in yoga.
Well,
let's just stop.
I mean,
acro yoga sounds really stupid,
but what is not is not really stupid.
No,
it's not.
And it's,
it's partner yoga involving gymnastic and acrobatic position.
So if you've ever seen,
say a Cirque de Solei performance with two strong men where they're linking arms
and holding handstands overhead and s and so on,
uh,
the motions are quite similar,
but you spend a lot of time on your back,
uh,
balancing people on your feet and so on.
And,
but the coming back to your squatting position,
I remember asking Jason,
I think his last name present Neemar really excellent coach.
Why he was recommending that I hold my hands a certain way when practicing
handstands because I've been instructed elsewhere by other,
uh,
gymnastics coach is to do it a different way.
And he said,
the reason you're holding it that way,
even though it's a little more uncomfortable,
is because when you go into the actual positions in Acro Yoga and you're doing
it at speed,
you're going to maintain that exact hand position.
So you want to train that pattern.
And I was like,
oh,
got it.
Yeah.
And uh,
let's talk about athleticism though.
The,
the training versus athleticism conversation.
Uh,
Kay and I hadn't heard of this because I,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not exposed to the crossfit games much,
but can you talk about the,
uh,
the softball phenomenon a bit?
Well,
I,
it's,
you know,
crossfit,
Eh,
you know,
as originally conceived by Greg Glassman.
And if you look at the original,
you know,
fitness in a hundred words or less in there,
it says regularly learn and play new sports.
Hey,
nice middle splits,
bro.
Well,
you started doing the middle splits.
We're sitting here on the floor in the gym and I was like,
I like getting,
get,
getting sort of the adductor jealousy.
So although your ties look like swollen texts and mine look like,
I just don't know.
I just woke up and I was like this bro.
I don't know how it came with the kit.
The um,
you know,
so the tenant always has been,
hey,
you've need to keep learning and you keep diversifying.
They call that lateralization.
Right?
People have been talking about it and surfers or some skill,
the big,
the big wall climber suddenly are doing breath holding and they learned
something about that.
Right.
Slap lining.
Yes,
exactly.
Lateralization right.
Steven Kotler has been all about him.
So that's an important piece of like saying,
okay,
you have this skill set,
let's go challenge it and no domain.
That's the crucial.
What is interesting and is always going to be a problem with for me with
crossfit is that,
um,
I can always,
you know,
crossfit is the sing for me,
the single best integrated way of training I have ever come across.
I still haven't seen it.
I've seen it refined,
I've seen Mckenzie apply it.
The concepts and principles to endurance athletes.
I've seen well born apply it to power athletes.
This,
the colonel and the methodology is the same.
Right.
But,
and I haven't to date seen something that looks better at general physical
preparedness.
Like I want my daughters to have a skillset and a base fitness and strength and,
and this is the,
the model is it,
the model is,
should I have all of my NFL is do something that looks exactly crossfit?
No,
but I can still keep the tenants there.
I can,
I the the thing,
the base code is so good.
The problem is sometimes we confuse the ability to do,
perform a lot of work with the ability to be athletic and in one of my
definitions of who's the best athletes,
who picks up the new skill the fastest.
This is why,
I mean your little experiment about the Tim Ferriss experiment about how fast
can I learn really piqued my interest because I'm like,
that is the,
the limiter.
How cow fast can I apply this base skill set?
What does,
what does that base skill set look like?
You remember?
Um,
uh,
Robert Highland had that little quote.
It was like a man should be able to,
I like butcher a hog captain,
a ship to etc. Etc.
Plan a war,
like I said,
a bone,
right?
Specializations for insects,
That like awesome,
strong girls in the background.
Oh,
if you heard that,
but the issue here is,
you know,
what we should be doing is trying to ask ourselves what constitutes the right
skillset to quickly pick up new skills and to reapply as myself once a learning
animal.
Him what I can tell you in my believe this in my soul souls and I've seen it
that good strength and conditioning programs and I'm talking about at all now,
right beyond crossfit,
good straightening into industry proof or programs reinforce skills in
positions.
Ido Portal for examples.
A good example of this,
right?
I don't,
I don't know if you know many of his guys are going to play in the NFL,
but that's not,
doesn't mean he hasn't,
he's right about this,
this concept,
but that,
you know,
how do we,
what's the language of creating a ready state in the human so that I can
constantly be not limited by my physical capacity and that is positioned to,
that's positionally driven.
That's my,
it's my ability to pick up and learn new skills.
And I think what you're referring to is in the crossfit games that we saw is
that people were freakish about their work capacity.
And then some people ask them,
let me be very strong,
huge Arabic engines and they were like,
just throw this ball and you're like,
what was the,
what was the event?
I didn't see it was a soft ball toss.
Any different this throws.
Yeah,
throw distance.
Throw the softball as far as you can now check this out.
It turns out that rich Froning played football in college.
Guess what?
He's a pretty good athlete.
Yeah.
Graham Homework to Sport College Athlete,
right?
Oh,
what did he do?
he was the pitcher and the quarterback,
like he's a mutant.
So he did all right.
Appreciating these guys store.
But there's some other kids who obviously had deficiencies in there,
have,
have thrived in because in crossfit,
but the nature and the limitations of challenging people's fitness,
it's hard to see the at the aspects of athleticism and it's not always the case.
They,
they really do try to program those things in.
But it's also limited by like,
how do we do with,
you know,
how do we have a pickup game of basketball?
I can't really see and judge that stuff.
Um,
you know,
they make people swim,
they make people run.
They me to go bike.
They paid the,
the obstacle course was a great example of the expression of just moving through
the environment.
I love that event.
Um,
but there were some people who had some really horrific soft,
they ended up rolling and underhand because,
and that really begs the question because the central tenant of what this
experiment was and it's important for,
I think the average person who is,
is crossfitting,
right?
Is that there's sort of two crossfits and I think crossfit HQ would back me up
on this,
that we have the highest expression of crossfitting,
which is the crossfit games.
And I just came from,
I'm an athlete camp that Reebok put on in The Bahamas.
I'm not going to lie.
It was okay.
Yes,
right.
But we did a bunch of train session with some of the best athletes on the
planet.
And the first thing that all of these Gamer guys did,
like these are the,
like these are rich Froning,
Jason Cleopas,
all the really extraordinary athletes.
They all went and played pick up football and onto masterfully boom immediately
and you're like,
Oh wow,
these guys are pretty legit athletes.
There was some aspect of that athleticism that they carried to crossfit and then
cross it allowed them to heighten this,
this a row,
this,
these functions.
And what I think happens sometimes is now,
because people can't sort of separate that out,
it's easy to put on a pedestal.
If I can just work really hard,
then I'm going to be a really good athlete and able to pick up all these new
sports.
And yes,
one of the things that I've seen Greg Cook pivot on and some people pivoting on
around crossfit as they didn't,
they realize that people aren't giving up capacities to crossfit right there.
They still are.
Most of us are still half full ankle range of motion.
Cause you do pistols additive not yes,
yes.
And,
and for a long time in the strength and conditioning world,
we have seen people get a really big power clean and then everything else sucks.
Right?
It all sucks.
So what's interesting about the program here in our gym is that we really ferret
out all the crappy wind patterns,
you know.
So let me ask you this.
If I could,
uh,
this is just top of mind right now,
I guess.
I guess two things.
If someone were to ask you,
is crossfit games really crossfit?
Should the multitudes of people in crossfit gyms aspire to that as an objective?
Number one,
let's start with number one.
Uh,
but,
uh,
got a bunch of top of mind.
But no,
first of all,
I don't think they should and,
but I will tell you that the athletes involved in the experiment involved has
been so informative for me as a coach,
as a physio,
because I can really see what the deficiencies are a day,
five at day three under these loads.
And,
and it really starts to matter when we see that the best athletes refined
position,
refined position,
refined efficiency and,
and win,
right?
That's,
that's been the name of the game.
It used to be that you could just outwork people that do people train and two
and three times a day.
They are the most meticulous athletes I've ever seen in any sport anywhere.
They're on top of the nutrition game,
on top of the recovery game,
on top of hydration,
adaptation,
mechanics.
Like they are really,
really have def,
I mean rich Froning,
he's a little tiny guy,
you know,
how much does he weigh?
I think he's probably like one 95 just something like that.
Snatches snatch three 15 that's like in tennis shoes and,
and Reebok flat nano shoes that like I can not,
not Olympic lifting shoes.
And he does that in the context of also being able to do all these other things.
So I think it's what it has done.
What the reason for me that the Games are so important is that it's,
it's changed the consciousness about what's possible.
By the way,
you can still run this mountain seven k and be brutally strong.
In fact,
why aren't you?
You know?
And I think people have been having that conversation for a long time.
It also has gotten us really clear about what works and doesn't work in a very
sort of pressure cooker situation in terms of programming and training load of
the pro programming.
But I would say about nutrition,
about,
I've never seen these,
any athlete in the history of the world do more work than these kids.
I know the Tour de France guys,
I,
I mean I know them personally and their wattage's are insane.
The run best runner,
like they're put,
everyone's putting out hard but no one like the CNS load,
the crazy loads.
And that has really made it very clear about the lessons that we've been able to
pull out.
So as an experiment,
as Formula One,
right?
But not all of us should aspire to be formula one drivers or even drive our
cars.
Like Formula One and very few of us have the genetics,
which is the also sort of yourself,
right?
The lie that we tell ourselves,
well you know,
I can train like them.
So I'm I,
you know,
no you can't.
You're not them genetically.
I'm sorry,
but sorry,
Tim Ferriss here.
A bad Bethel.
I sit in the corner.
You know what?
Play scrabble.
You are relatively strong.
You're strong ish.
I strong as your aerobic fit.
Good thing you're a smart kid and you're good to answer.
People don't know that about you.
And I learned to throw the genuineness of the people who are stronger and I can
run away.
So,
you know,
I think,
I think that it's vital to understand the role of the games have played in terms
of raising the boat.
Also sort of distilling down the essences of what's important and not important
and the lessons we've learned out of that and how to program.
You know,
cause I think a long time ago,
you know,
even guys like Louie was like,
well we're all powerlifter so we'll just plot powerlifting.
Well that didn't work at all.
Right?
And what we're seeing is very sophisticated training,
a mega wave heart rate variability,
like what people are doing.
It's a way of sort of looking at bow rhythms,
heart rate variability,
and really coming up with recovery score so we can understand in real time the
effect of yesterday's training.
The HRV would be part of that.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But like like Hrv on steroids,
right?
And so what's amazing now is we see that level of sophistication and I've been
able to take that and apply it to the NFL and you know,
I mean not like hey we do thrusters,
we're going to be good the NFL,
but really the principles and also it's given me the view of understanding all
the corners that were missing,
right?
That you have to have the corners of your range of motion and capacities.
Otherwise we're going to have issues.
What do you mean by corners?
Well,
sort of the edge cases like this is the 10% case.
More like show me that you actually,
you don't have 85% ish of your shoulder range,
but you have stability and capacity in the fullest end ranges.
So in the corners of your range of motion,
right?
So all the way overhead is one of those corners.
Have my arm over my head.
Like if you're not,
if you can't hold two dumbbells over your head with your arms,
like straight,
like you're hand holding like hammers and your rib cage down,
that's an incomplete position and it's that position that's costing you when you
swim is that position with costing you when you throw a ball,
it's that inefficiency that's costing when you fall.
Now we have a way of really understanding and what I've been able to do is for
me,
I've been able to repurpose crossfit into the greatest diagnostic tool ever.
And it's independent of you breathing heart,
right?
The intensity is an important piece that other people don't understand.
So the GPP that everyone has been talking about for a gazillion years,
general physical parents,
the Russians I think invented that word,
right?
And they,
and they got into their like,
you have to be able to jump off a ladder,
you without your knees wobbling.
That was a really simple way of just loading a squat.
Right?
That was,
that's what that was.
It's not mystical.
You know,
what we said for a long time was,
you know,
get your kid in gymnastics,
that's really good.
We'll make good athletes were,
look,
what the fuck does that matter?
Like really tell me why.
Well,
it turns out that the,
the things that you have to be able to do in gymnastics teach you certain
positions and principles that you can then apply it.
Use your skeleton,
not just your muscles.
Yes.
And then we can get away with,
you know,
big muscle bound guys to get their asses kicked,
like,
you know,
or the little skinny cardio whippet who falls apart,
can't lift 60 kilos off the ground when they're breathing a little bit hard.
Like those are both ends of the spectrum that aren't good.
What,
you mentioned nutrition and I've got a bunch of a bunch of questions,
but uh,
in,
in brief,
what would you say are the most common nutrition mistakes or,
uh,
let's see,
detrimental beliefs that crossfitters have?
Well,
this is the first for a lot of us,
me included,
you know,
I'd actually heard,
the zone was the first thing that you know,
that Greg talked about as well.
Back when I was first training in a crossfit mine,
I think I've told you this before,
but back when the Santa Cruz guys would come to mountain view to train at the
health Gracie gas,
it was all about the zone.
And I remember training with those guys.
Well,
and so again,
let's,
let's get to understanding why that mattered.
Because People's macronutrients there combinations in terms of what they were
eating was way,
way out of,
was wacky,
not eating any fat,
not barely getting enough protein,
massive amounts of carbohydrate.
And that was the first way we could just identify the problem,
right?
So,
but then we started measuring and Langston and we had an idea of what roughly
we're taking it.
And to this day I look at a bed and I'm like three blocks,
you know,
that's 30 grams of carbohydrate that you know,
like,
uh,
it's been useful.
It's like a unit,
like a metric unit,
right?
That's a kilometer.
That's a meter,
right?
It gives me a baseline of understanding how much food I need to be eating.
But then,
and it was always about food quality.
That was always an important conversation.
But then people would be like,
well,
I can eat this bacon and drink this beer and I'm still in the zone.
And it was a room I come on,
you know?
And so what,
what happened then was that we saw this Paleo revolution wash over the
crossfitter.
So I were like,
and I,
the first time I said this to my wife,
Juliet,
bless her little heart,
was like,
she googles on line because Juliet is the biggest skeptic.
And she was like,
this is some bullshit.
I'm like,
what?
She's like,
the first thing that came up was a hornet's nest soup.
Like wasp nest soup.
Kelly.
She's like,
that's what you fucking mean.
And I was like,
I don't,
I think it means no grains,
you know,
and we should eat vegetables.
And she's like,
this is some bullshit.
But that was really,
again,
a conversation about food quality.
Right?
Well.
Then we saw this rubber bushing,
Juliet.
Literally,
it's just not the greatest bullshit detector.
Thank you everyone.
Everyone's get yourself a Juliet.
But then what we saw was that everyone got super squeaky clean,
like didn't even use salt,
and I was like,
Oh,
you know,
salt is really useful.
I saw a bunch of my friends who cleaned up their diet and they were,
they literally tanked like they were blacking out because they weren't getting
any salts ever.
Like we,
there's this thing called salt.
It's amazing.
Humans invented the salt routes forehead,
right?
It,
I read a study on primates and why humans are so fund of Fructose,
the naturally occurring sugar in fruit and why it's so problematic to have,
say high fructose corn syrup or Gabi Nectar.
It's like 75% plus fructose and we get fatty liver disease.
When we were migrating apes,
the way that we would sustain higher blood pressure without salt was with fruit.
Oh,
isn't that make perfect sense?
Yeah,
it makes perfect sense.
But yeah,
salt,
guess what folks?
Pretty important or like blood pressure.
It's so important.
Like Stacy sims is a good homey of ours,
right?
She is a exercise physiologist out of Stanford.
She's been exercise physio to the best athletes on the planet best,
especially the best aerobic athletes.
But she assists everyone.
Her company is called Osmo nutrition.
And Her thinking about hydration is vital,
but she's like,
hey,
there's this stuff called sea salt.
Take a pinch of it,
throw it in your water and quit being a jerk and diluting yourself.
I,
you know,
not diluting,
diluting.
Right?
And what we've seen is that people are not applying the lessons of that we've
learned in sport for the last 2030 40 years to day to day life.
So people got really squeaky clean and they could not eat enough carbohydrate to
support the level of training that we're doing.
Right?
And all the endurance athletes were like,
dude,
you can't eat a hundred grams of carbohydrate a day and expect to thrive and or
just be a Keto adapted athlete.
I'm like,
yeah,
that works if I have to do it.
But man,
that's,
that's not working for me.
So well,
you have to be very meticulous genetics to really support that,
you know,
and like boot,
oh I,
I looked at some sugar,
now I'm not keto adapted.
Right.
And you know,
the key is always,
and this has always been the crossfit HQ position for one,
number one eat enough carbohydrate to support exercise.
Well,
I've taken a finally figured out what that means.
Right?
And that's a fluctuating norm,
you know,
and also in the last 10 years we have figured out,
for example,
through the miraculousness of blood testing of genetic testing,
like we can actually get that stuff now done pretty easily.
It turns out,
for example,
I'm going to Roebuck responder means big aerobic workouts caused my body to be
like in Nirvana and power athletes stuff.
I have to train that stuff of course.
But that is not where I should be making my money.
Why my genetics tell me.
And it's interesting that any success I've had as an athlete,
I basically have been swimming against that stream my whole life.
Right.
Well,
my genetics also tell me that I don't process saturated fats very well.
And they call it lean Paleo,
which means eat high quality food,
Kelly,
but you don't need bacon every day.
I don't eat bacon everyday and I don't eat nuts.
Cause when I do my cholesterol goes through the roof.
And I know we can be sophisticate about cholesterol,
but when your cholesterol is 400,
like there's something up,
right.
That's not,
you know,
and I had a bunch of friends,
galleries in a whopper.
That's right.
So I think that's the,
what we found is that people have gone back to rice.
They've gone back to,
you know,
hey,
I've got a source my carbohydrate intelligently in order to support the amount
of training I'm doing.
And that was,
that was,
I think a reaction.
People are less afraid of gluten.
I think they're really try to stay away from it.
You know,
maybe that's just Monsanto that's talking there,
but uh,
you know,
that's how you're gonna have to edit that out.
Sorry to no,
no,
no.
They'll send a letter about the house,
not mine.
Just kidding.
I love you.
Must not tell that one.
You know what's funny about weeds?
Nothing's funny about weeds.
So no,
the,
the bottom line is I think we've seen that correction,
but once again,
we should take that lesson from the highest level sport.
That's what coaches are trying to do.
Distill principles,
not methods.
And also I think particularly when it comes to Macros,
is know thyself and know thy sport or training load.
Right.
So Pete a Tia,
Dr [inaudible] who you've met,
have you ever spent any time with who you have to meet this guy?
You guys would love each other,
but uh,
he was on the podcast.
We talked about cancer research,
but he's also,
he would,
is he the,
he's the sugar cancer connection guy?
Well,
I,
he would talk about that certainly.
But he is a,
he was a former oncology researcher.
He's also been a surgeon and he's a high level,
he would not want me to say high level,
but he's a high level endurance athlete,
you know,
a hundred mile swims and things like that.
Well,
that high level.
And he's also,
but he's also very strong for his,
for his bodyweight.
And he,
he loves doing time trials for cycling.
And so he is almost always Quito adoptees and Coteau sis.
For those people who haven't heard my conversation with Peta Tiaa,
all that means is you're,
you're,
you're utilizing fat.
This is highly simplified but fat instead of glucose as,
as your primary fuel.
And when he's doing these intense rides though,
he,
he knows exactly his respiratory quotient when he kicks over to anaerobic and
how many calories he can consume and how many calories is his liver can store so
that he never comes out of Ketosis.
So he can be pounding gels,
but he's like,
okay,
I know that my liver at my body weight,
I'm going to store about 400 calories of carbohydrates based on based this
target distance and this target,
wattage,
et cetera.
I can end my race and still be in Ketosis or my time trial.
Uh,
but that's because my problem with that of course,
is that that's true.
And he is the freakish outlier.
Nobody's going to do data right.
And very few people are going to do that.
Um,
that's amazing.
But,
but what's,
what's fascinating is,
um,
so yeah,
the Paleo,
the Paleo community.
What are,
what are other,
are there any other common dietary mistakes that you feel?
People,
terrible round water.
The coffee has been the cult like black fluid,
what do we call it?
The Cup of fear.
Cup of fear,
cover fair.
And uh,
you know,
people are like,
I don't need a drink.
Water,
drink coffee all day long.
And then this kill cliff,
you know,
which is an amazing crossfit soda,
that it's not related to crossfit,
but it's sponsored by some crop.
Anyway,
you get the idea.
It's amazing with vodka too,
by the way,
but which is also can be gluten free.
So you're still paleo,
it's fine.
But I think what we're seeing is that,
you know,
you can eat,
here's,
here's what's crucial.
You can be at 80% of your function and come in and do relatively okay once you
move.
Well,
once you've been doing this for a while,
you can just be on the edges of your sleep on the,
you know,
borderline,
eat some extra ice cream,
you know,
budge a little bit,
not deal with stress done,
but of course we know all of those things.
I've got to keep an eye on.
This is what a physical practices and what we've seen then is for me,
it's important that you're actually signing up for a race.
You're signing up for an event.
The gym is not the event.
This is the place where we train and yes,
it feels like competition to hear because I,
it's intense.
It's deep practice.
Daniel.
Cool.
Thank you.
It's,
it's me really,
really practicing.
Telecode that's right.
Nice Dude.
Uh,
it's,
it's deep intention.
It's harder aerobic conditioning,
but it's still not the same thing as stepping into a ring or of lining up on a
five k or signing up.
And what you realize is how important all those aspects of our to your,
your,
your training,
you have to eat.
Right.
That's why I'm like,
look,
the crossfit is doing it because it does the crossfit open,
which is the biggest sporting event in the history of mankind.
That's what it is.
Every year,
more people sign up for the crossfit open,
they do five workouts and then,
and it's a big international competition,
right?
It's a virtual game.
It's a virtual games basically.
It's a,
it's a feeder to regionals.
So you know,
whether you like it or not,
I'm like,
why don't you do it and for no other reason then why don't you have something
hanging over your head for five weeks in a row?
Because that's really,
which also gives you a target other than the next more phase Wad.
Yes.
It's a,
you can actually decide what the optimal diet is.
Given that five week goal,
you just make a whole bunch of different decisions.
You know what,
when they say,
I mean deadlines focus the mind,
you know,
Mr deadline guy and uh,
he'll stay up all night because you realize you're like,
wow,
it really does force.
You know,
you're thinking about this.
And I think that's,
that's what sometimes gets lost in the crossfit gym.
Initially it was terrifying.
I didn't know if I was going to survive.
Let me give an example.
When I started this thing 10 years ago,
Adrian Bosman who was a,
you know,
crossfit headquarters,
Uber Manch right.
And,
and he was one of our first coaches.
I did all the coaching.
We,
this was all unknown.
There were,
we were the 27th Crossfit,
I think officially 50th now like 27 on the list.
How many are there total?
11,000 roughly.
Which is a revolution.
You,
I mean it's not a gimmick.
And what ends up happening was there was a workout that was snatch 135 pounds 30
times Adriana and I didn't know we could do it.
We didn't know anyone who had done it except like Olympic lifters,
you know,
who would like seriously trained and we're strong.
And one day we're like,
we're going to do this.
Even if it takes us all day and like we psych ourselves up and like now they
throw that as like an after effect.
You can do that in 90 seconds.
I mean,
things have changed dramatically in 10 years because w you know,
it's like the four minute mile,
everyone's like,
oh,
you're still running a four minute miles is so quaint.
We're in the one minute mile now.
And um,
but you know,
10 years we didn't know.
And so now we're starting to see that,
you know,
what's,
what's possible.
Yeah,
for sure.
Coming back to this notch for a second.
Um,
so I've never been a a practitioner of Olympic lifts for a whole host of
reasons,
but primarily because I had reconstructive shoulder surgery in 2004 doing a
silly stuff like grappling that made my arm straight out of the front of my
chest.
And maybe you should have been Olympic with this,
so maybe I should have.
So I had a lot of apprehension about spitefully sound like terminal,
it's going to overhead last 15,
20 degrees.
And uh,
but I found a lot of value,
particularly in the last six months or so with focusing on overhead squatting
movements.
Yeah.
Still not to the point where I'm going to do snatches.
Uh,
and I think that's where I've become smarter over the years is recognizing that
you can,
you can really refine that movement patterns.
I don't have the go heavy go big or go home mentality anymore that I used to
because the,
the risk benefits so unfavorable to me.
But uh,
why is rich Froning so good at the snatch and what are the common mistakes that
people make with that movement?
Well,
rich has excellent mechanics,
has full range of motion,
his ankles,
his excellent shoulder range and understanding of stability.
He's able to get me,
he just does things that are naturally important.
A snatching.
He does them effortlessly in terms of getting his torso upright.
His history,
obviously it's a lot of training stimulus and these things,
but he understands how to create stable shapes and he's able to get into those
shapes who doesn't have to work very hard.
The,
the,
the work he does goes into it's,
he gets 100% benefit from that.
He doesn't have to,
he's not working at 80% of 70% efficiency.
Does that make sense?
That makes sense.
He's,
he's working hard on the shapes.
What you,
what you discovered though is I think underlying the center,
you know it's a part of the functional movement screen since 1986 Dan John is
like all we see all this throw her say I wish I had overhead squat more Glassman
valued.
It is like the one of the most important capacities and in fact one of the
earliest best crossfit workouts,
I think it's called Nancy and it's run 400 meters.
So innocuous,
right?
And then just overhead squat 95 pounds,
15 times like I'm sick.
Like that's pink a weight,
but just 15 tenths,
400 meters doesn't some,
Pete didn't know if you don't have to overhead squat 1595 pounds,
15 times run 400 meters and then just do that.
Oh I said just do that like five times and what you're going to see where they
quickly is when it happens,
like everyone can fake it for three,
but then as you start to fatigue or your,
your,
your positions aren't robust,
you bounce off the tent,
you're no longer have access.
Right.
And you know,
you start,
the world gets really small.
And then you start suffering and then you eventually Labrador retriever in the
close sliding door.
That's true factory.
So you know,
I think what is key is understanding what are the salient positions.
You know,
all we're doing,
we say overhead squad is,
I'm saying show me you can squat with your torso upright and that looks a lot
like sport,
doesn't it?
And if you have to lean forward where the far to do that,
then it says you have incomplete hip and ankle function and you don't know how
to create stability in your trunk.
And that is a very powerful idea.
Right.
And what's nice about the overhead squat is,
I call it a category when movement,
I can get very organized and I can grind down to a position where either either
we agree that it's full range of motion or not,
or two,
I start to lose position and come back up.
What I've removed out of it as the element of speed.
So for my nine year old,
for example,
Georgia,
the overhead squat is something we do all the time.
Sometimes we just bring the little kitty barbell into the,
into the living room.
If she goes to bed or even less,
maybe 10 pounds and she just has to do three sets of five.
Why it's practicing the shape,
practicing the position and that's where we're going to get bang for the buck.
Do you,
you can pull,
you don't need a snatch heavy.
Do you think should be any cross fitters focus on working out and not
practicing?
Well,
totally and I would say that that let,
let's,
let's take it out across it for a second and let's put it into running.
Sure.
Running is a very,
very technical skill that we should be developing from a very early age and
there are only like what,
30 million renters in America through who run three times a week and only 80% of
them are injured in a year.
That's like the worst statistic ever.
Listen,
if you're listening to this,
do not let your children run.
It's dangerous.
Comma,
if you're a runner and running is the f one,
one of the things that makes us human,
you should be able to run that is one of the tenants of being a good athlete.
In fact,
looked at the NFL combine for example,
they jump right?
They have to bench press,
which is a joke.
That's the one piece.
It's a joke,
but everything else is a run drill,
change direction,
Jill.
It's about fluency and economy of running and changing mechanics.
No wonder a couple of years in crossfit put this big like you know cone drill
thing in there because they were like,
hey look this thing,
you should be really competent in that and you're going to get punished if you
suck at it.
So if we look at most people's running,
how much actual skill development did they do in running?
You mean besides tying your shoes next?
None.
And they just start running less year with say a Joe to Franco,
planning on being in the NFL combine.
And he's like,
actually if you're right handed,
you should switch your feet this way because you cut one step at a shuttle run
and then wow,
now you're a super fan.
Joe Does a whole bunch of stuff about being,
do you have the positions to run?
Like for me,
the most dangerous sport to middle aged men is a track workout.
Oh my God.
So dangerous.
Like you're just asking for a pulled hamstring or torn cap because you're at the
end ranges and when you start,
your back starts to deflect because you can't buffer,
you're,
you know,
you're huge engine brand.
Then you have a neuro mechanical compromise.
Tear hamstring.
It's the same thing happens in basketball.
We don't even talk about what the end,
what do you have the required range of motion to run?
Yes or no?
And resoundingly the answer is Hell No.
And do we do any skills or drills about improving economy?
No.
So what ends up happening of course,
is that we should,
and what's what I can tell you that I see is that I see very,
very intelligent coaches practicing skills,
teaching skills,
and then challenging those skills in a workout.
And that is good programming.
So if I am getting to a point where I'm comfortable with overhead squatting with
the barbell and can that never happens by the way,
cause it always,
it always gets worse.
Well,
I've,
uh,
you should have,
I'll send you some photos.
They're hilarious.
Uh,
the,
uh,
if I'm considering going into say,
training for the snatch,
what are common mistakes that I should be aware of that I should avoid?
Well,
you know,
we have basically been able to break those fundamental positions down.
So how about this?
Show me that you can actually put,
you know,
just put some tens on the bark,
right?
A women's bar.
Make it a really light,
you know,
but it could be that you can a little bit,
hey,
they're called dwarf hands.
All right.
Yeah.
And,
and one of the issues is,
you know,
show me,
you can keep your back flat and actually get to the bar.
And what you're going to see is that people can't do that.
Get to the bunk.
Getting to the bar.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Just get into the setup position for the garden.
And what you're going to find is that people can't even get into a decent setup
position without rounding the back and dumping their shoulders.
And then we start asking the question,
what the hell are we doing?
Your setup position is so set up cheating that bottom.
Can you show me?
You put your hands in a snatch grip and then sit all the way down on your,
on your ankles,
right?
Sit down and get into a good position.
What you're gonna find is that people,
university can't do that.
So suddenly I've learned something about myself.
Why do all the best coaches teach from the hang while we teach from the hang?
Then I take that portion out of it.
I can derive a lot of the benefits from snatching without taking you to these
compromised shapes.
And the problem is I know you can snatch from that compromise shape,
but that's not the shape we all agree is the best shape does that make?
So if you can't even get all the way down to the bar,
an issue of technique is never,
we're never going to solve this because you're making basic type one errors from
the first inch off the ground floor in centimeters cause everything's in kilos
in Olympic lifting.
Let me ask you,
I want to put you on the spot for a second cause I've always wanted to ask you
this and I'm not sure why I haven't.
Uh,
yes,
these are my real calves.
They're not Catholic.
I was curious about your testicles all surreal.
No,
it's just the left.
I noticed you only put one in.
Just testing it out.
Uh,
the uh,
if you worked,
if you had to remove three common exercises from crossfit gyms in the interest
of safety,
what would they be?
So if you had two gun against the head,
well it doesn't have to be three,
three.
Let me deconstruct that for a second.
And that's crucial because first and foremost,
all the movements in the training language are inherently safe.
If you have full range of motion in the motor control of doom,
right?
So presumably though you get a thousand people come in,
there are certain exercises where a higher percentage of those people will lack
that prerequisite.
But the number one most dangerous skill bench press and why?
Because people don't have any internal rotation of their shoulder.
They've pinned there back down,
right?
Let's you can press all day long standing overhead,
military press press,
you're going to fail safely.
When you fail in a bench press that shoulders is,
it's going to translate forward.
There's your labor on those.
You can you bench rest safely?
Yes.
Do we love floor pressing in our gym?
Absolutely.
We floor press a ton,
but what I find is that people do not have the basic mechanics and that's one of
the ways that we've gotten our head that we define like you know,
we define strike how much you bench,
you know,
how much you bench.
You know,
my friend Mark Bell,
then just over 900,
our friend Mark Bell,
our friend Mark Sally.
And uh,
you know,
that's an amazing amount.
And what I will tell you is that it's his positions and mechanics.
It is so technical.
Like I think I once it became hyper-technical and all sorts,
the assistants work and everything that he does related to it,
it's so sophisticated.
I think f after knowing mark and Jesse Burdick for several years,
I fee,
I feel like I finally learned how to bench press even though I've been
benchpressing since I was what,
like a man,
I came out like,
like my testicles drop and they handed me a bench press,
you know.
And uh,
so I mean I've said I pulled the bench out of that.
I also will pull the rings out rings.
And the reason is what we see is that people can do movements that looked like
ring dips.
They go up and down,
but they don't lock out the shoulders in terrible positions.
And what we value is them doing work,
going up and down.
But if we put the rings back in for Stability Work,
show me you have a good start position and finish position.
Like here's what,
here's what I promise.
Like the TRX is a great piece of home equipment like you can,
one of the things that I'm a big fan of,
it's understanding that if your hands are on the ground doing a pushup,
right,
then you can cheat off the ground.
You have what I call a closed torque environment.
If you grew up a barbell that's close,
close Torque,
it's basically a circuit,
right?
And I can create stability off that in really strange positions cause I can
still join the rending the bar.
That's right.
I should be bending the bar,
but I can still bend the bar even though my body's and really strange shapes,
as soon as they put a dumbbell in your hand,
you can't do that in different game.
Right?
That's why kettlebells are so important.
My dumbbells are so important because they,
I call it an open torque system.
I have to create all the stability at the big primary engine.
I can't cheat it up through the chain.
And so why are ring so important?
Well,
one of the reasons rings,
dips are important is because they forced me to show my hand what's really going
on at the shoulder and an open torque environment.
The problem.
So one of the reasons this TRX is great is that you're basically taking really
simple movements and being able to apply this.
I'm in a strap,
I'm hanging right?
And I can't cheat anymore,
right?
Because I,
if I'm disorganized at the shoulder,
I don't,
I don't try to force.
So,
but the problem is with the rings that you can still cheat yourself in
internally and try road into an terribly internally rotated position,
cranking your neck back and you can still go up and down until you can't.
And um,
and remember the gym is a diagnostic tool should be figuring out what's going
on.
I think the shoulder,
we'll hand the hips will handle a lot more silly bs a lot longer than the
shoulder will.
Right?
If I had to pull out one more movement,
you know,
hand against the gun against the wall.
I would say the butterfly Kipp only because I think it's,
that's how I,
if you asked me to do a bunch of pullups,
guess what I'm going to do butterfly kit.
But I understand the principles and I have good range of motion.
It's a completely safe position.
But what we see is that people do not have,
I asked them to put their arms over their head for example.
Right?
And they can't do it.
And then so suddenly magically hanging from a bar is going to increase that
range of motion or they're going to compensate then swinging and lending.
So what we do is we add speed to a bad position and then that's really the
recipe.
Capell goes the lion.
That's right once,
but once again,
you know,
we program all that stuff on our gym,
but you'll notice that we have a lot of static ring stations because what we saw
as well,
people can't even do,
you can't even get into the start position on the rings,
which is elbows locked out.
But squeeze thumbs turned out they can't even get into the finish position or
the start position.
So what are we talking about?
You know,
what we're doing is we're ended up arguing about bullshit,
right?
You,
you can't even get into the bottom position of a snatch.
Why are we talking about your snatch?
Right?
And I mean I'm getting into more gymnastics,
uh,
these days and uh,
know I want to be able to do it back tuck.
I've never been able to do a back tuck.
And really,
yeah,
attribute wise,
I have the attributes but it's a long story because I was obsessed with that
too.
So I want to get to that point.
You can do that safely,
but you can certainly do it very,
very unsafely or attempt to do it unsafely.
And I think that the question of sequencing and how you put things in a proper
order from diagnostics to refinement to training,
we have not given people the background or the language of how their bodies
work.
You know,
I get to work with kids like children,
like first graders in some kindergarteners in our swim team all the way up to
master's Olympic athletes.
I mean,
like we,
I've see it all right?
And what I can tell you is that most along the way,
no one gets any formal training.
And the mistake has been always like,
I think crossfit is doing it more,
right?
The defrank goes gyms,
the Mike Boyle's,
the places like that are,
you know,
Shan Turley at Stanford.
There are pockets of really excellent thinkers who are teaching people how to
move.
And that's a specific thing,
right?
And that's not just jumping back and forth and chasing a bouncy ball.
That's very specific skills and challenging those skills with the things we
talked about.
So you know,
what we've seen is a decentralized and cross for samples that could decentralize
Soviet sports system.
Why do we have 11,000 states?
And what you'll see is that kids will grow up through the crossroads system and
a generation and they will ha,
they'll already be like,
of course I'm going overhead squat.
What?
I mean,
why can't you overhead squat,
you know what I mean?
And we'll solve a lot of problems.
But the,
the key pieces,
we can't confuse exercising for full human capacity.
That's,
that's the missing link.
And speaking of full human capacity,
if you look at the most elite crossfitters,
what are,
are there things that they do that the lower ranks do not commonalities that
you've observed that people can,
can borrow or emulate or incorporated?
You're saying that that top crossfitters that the bottom aren't doing that just
the recreational?
Yeah,
like the top,
top,
core tile or decile.
They,
uh,
they all have,
most of them I know are obsessed with mechanics,
most of them,
and really spend a lot of time refining that mechanics.
Um,
that's really,
you know,
their positions are more effortless.
Like there was a,
uh,
you know,
I this physical therapy instructor and she was like,
she,
she taught pediatrics and she's like,
let me be fucking clear.
Muscles and tissues are like obedient dogs.
And I was like,
like my mind was like Douche.
Like this is coming from the pediatric physical therapist who was like,
what the Hell's wrong with you?
Why?
You know,
why are you so stiff?
and um,
you know,
in the,
the key the we're doing synchronized stretches is,
um,
the,
the key is that people aren't spending enough time working on full position.
And maybe it's because I have not made the case for it because what we've done
is we know you can get by at 80%,
but show me you have full capacity because that's the thing that these top
athletes have.
I mean,
they obviously can work with the home,
meaning the corners of these position,
positional put full position,
and I always use this example,
but squat down with your feet together,
keep your heels on the ground,
needs together.
Can you do that?
Yes or no.
If he can't do that needs together all the way down,
chilling out in the bottom,
like we're on a campfire,
then you're missing full hip range of motion,
ankle range of motion.
One of those things is missing and that's the mechanism for your hip
impingement.
That's the mechanism for your plantar Fasciitis,
for your Bunyan,
for your torn Achilles.
You know,
for years pulled Catholic.
That is the fucking problem.
And you should be obsessing about this.
You know,
crossfit is like it's or any good modern strength conditioning system because
we're not the only ones doing it now,
but they force us into these shapes that are diagnostic.
You know,
and you know,
if you've been around Pawel will then you probably have done a pistol at some
point.
Sure.
That's because you have to be able to have that open torque control on your leg,
right?
That's how he gets away with not having to do lots of step ups.
Right.
Show me that you can squat up and down one leg with that strength and
immediately you can tell if you have the ankle range of motion,
hip range of motion to do that.
Right.
So it's interesting that that got pulled into the language because it was so
diagnostic.
If,
if there were two or three movements that people listening to this could
videotape themselves performing for sort of maximal diagnostic value,
uh,
let's just say it's busy professional who's like,
Eh,
you know,
I'm probably letting go but I want to get back into training.
I want to be able to videotape myself at certain points just to see how screwed
up I am before I tried to do something I did when I was 20 years old.
Is there anything in particular you'd recommend?
Well,
here's the problem with that is that you somehow devalue some of the other
positions.
And in,
in physical therapy school,
they had this great statement in there like test something you think you changed
and something you didn't think you changed.
And now it's like,
so it turned on an amazing and then I was like,
well fuck,
it's my fucking shoulder and if I'm compromised on this end,
I maybe don't have the intellectual capacity to understand how that compromises
me on the other side.
And so what,
what's crucial is that you can go from the start position.
So,
for example,
you may not think that Olympic lifting is important to you as a swimmer,
but Olympic lifting forces you all the time or swinging kettlebells into having
full internal rotation of your shoulder.
So even just doing the Bergner warmup with a PVC pipe is,
um,
he's an Olympic lifting coach.
You can Google Bergner warmup.
How do you spell his name?
It's like B,
Got it.
And if Mike Bergner and if you just get into this high hang position,
like,
like you're doing like the robot dance out to the side,
right?
All the time,
you should be able to get your hand all the way down to your hip and your
shoulders shouldn't twist forward.
So people are like,
oh,
I don't need to Olympic lift.
Well you should be able to snatch PVC pipe without hurting your shoulder.
But those same people will go to the pool and not recognize that the finish
position for the crawl stroke is the same business,
same position.
And so what ends up happening then is in the swimming language,
if I'm missing that intern rotation at the end,
that means my shoulder comes forward and that means my next stroke is
compromised.
And that's why you have to have full range on both ends of your shoulder.
Right?
Because I'm going to compromise and that's going to mess up my next start or my
next rep.
I've been amazed how much my entire physiology has changed.
Just focusing on terminal knee extension,
just like lay on your back,
put your legs straight up in the air,
pull your toes back,
straighten your legs,
and if he can't straighten them completely.
I was like,
wow,
my legs are shaking.
Like you know,
I hadn't handed that over to two.
NFL is today who were were,
were,
were coming back from an ACL repair.
That tea,
they sit all day long,
they're sending 14 hours a day and knees slightly bent.
They don't have that range.
Post to your chain is,
you know you should,
why can't you do a long sit?
You know,
last time you saw me I could barely do this and now I'm like,
that's right out to the one of the things that you,
the truth,
Pr Lifetime,
one of the,
one of the truths is that you know we're always talking about putting the hip
back into the socket.
Like that's the capsule stretch.
That's four hour body stuff.
Definitely,
but what you figured out was,
boy,
if I,
if I have some more,
some load,
my legs are up and I put some load to that,
that's seated that hip back into the position and reinforce that mechanic and
then you had to be stable in that shape.
Same thing happens when you squat.
Theoretically,
same things should be happening when you deadlift,
but what we see is that the modernness of us is what messes us up.
You have to have a movement practice [inaudible] practice yogas,
movement,
practice.
Acro Yoga is moving practice because they're exposed crossfits moon practice,
but then I also have to probably breathe hard a little bit.
Someone there and get stronger and you're moving practice can handle that can be
kettlebells based.
I,
you can go to the Olympics that way.
And then the last piece of course,
is that you have to be able to take care of your tissues.
You have to know how to do some basic maintenance.
You know,
one of the reasons that far body spoke to so many people,
it was a,
it was like you gave them a blueprint,
a Betty Crocker cookbook of how their body worked and the things that they can
do that were actionable that didn't require a doctor,
a physical therapist.
That's the revolution.
Thank you.
Uh,
thank you for helping with that.
Also,
I have to ask this.
This is,
this is a,
it's a common question.
It's not one that I ask myself much,
but I'm curious how you would answer it.
Is Cross it a fad.
I would say totally,
totally a fat because front squatting and running as a fad,
it's a gimmick.
No,
look,
gymnastics is not a gimmick.
Olympic lifting,
not a gimmick.
Power lifting,
You know,
one of the things that I don't think people really recognize crossfit so much
and you can even go,
go back to Paul's book.
It's like he interviews some MMA guy was legendary for his conditioning.
He does the hundred Kettlebell snatch test.
He doesn't like eight minutes and it destroys him.
Like I have 13 year old girls who can do that version of that thing and like
three and a half minutes.
No,
I mean,
so we we've done is we've gotten a lot better conditioned and,
and I think people understand that crossfit has always prioritized conditioning
and Roebuck engine first.
You've got to take care of that stuff and the body weight control stuff is the
easiest way and the most democratized way.
Then let's have a conversation about how much you weigh,
how strong you are.
If you give me the best of the crossfit games,
you're going to have to be really,
really strong and really Rubik for rest of us.
We can keep putting money in that strength bank,
but that,
that aerobic functioning bank,
it goes dry.
Uh,
the conditioning to a and a,
I know you got got a bunch of people to train here and business to handle so
I'll let you go in a minute.
But the to thin slice conditioning for a second because for for me,
of course I want to,
I want to dig into the measurables.
Is that primarily when I look at say a metabolic conditioning workout,
a metcon workout,
is it primarily trying to push up that anaerobic threshold so that you don't get
crippled by lactic acid and the hydrogen ions and all that and puke into a
bucket a is a vo two Max.
Like what are the primary components that you can kind of perform that you can
track?
The idea is that,
you know,
we could maintain all these other functions,
strength,
power,
all the things that sort of valued us as a powerful functional people and I
could get all the benefits of the aerobic anaerobic training with intervals like
training,
high intensity training,
right.
Izumi Tabata prove that along time ago.
But we found is that,
hey,
probably you need to go long once in a while to make sure you can and there are
some adaptations that only happen at that long steady state,
right?
I'm about to,
I'm signed up for the Molokai.
I'm Palen Osi one.
It's like a five to seven hour race.
20 minute workouts are not going to do it from the sea kayaking,
outrigger canoe,
outrigger canoe.
Right.
But my point is that I'm going to have to go long how long we need to go is up
to my coach.
You know,
I'm probably not doing longer than an hour still maintaining respecting this
robot piece,
but that the intensity,
you know,
all of our energy systems work in concert and out the same time.
You know,
if you go longer than two minutes,
two minutes is a 50% of aerobic,
50% anaerobic effort.
So you know,
running,
you know it's six minutes,
eight minutes,
your full robot power.
You know that,
that's a much more interesting do one k repeats.
You know,
that's something that people don't understand about Brian Mckenzie's model.
it's like he asked me to do five k repeats and stuff and on the Erg and poo,
it's brutal.
That's brutal.
Is the standing or seated her?
That'd be the scourge.
The skier,
the skier,
you know.
Got It.
You know,
that's,
that's a tea.
Those are terrible places to be,
you know,
one k repeats,
and I think we even,
people are not afraid of working hard anymore.
We've gotten past that.
Now let's have a little bit better conversation.
What,
uh,
what do you think is the future of crossfit?
You can as way you want it.
Well,
you know,
it's going to continue to refine itself.
I think people are coming in and all the coaches I know and work with,
you know,
are starting to understand what is we're doing and how sophisticated.
It's not just,
we just don't throw a bunch of random shit up and exercise until we puke.
You know,
it seems like that,
you know,
bunch of bunch of jerks swinging around the bar.
That's not what's happening at all.
There are some jerks swinging on the bar that happens.
I mean,
I always point out on like the physical therapist out in the world,
you had a business long before crossfit,
Fyi.
Like there are people have been fucking themselves up in every sport for as long
as when people,
because we're ego driven people because we're,
we're driven to perform,
right?
So,
you know,
the key is to pull your ego out of this and really play the long game.
What do you look like?
How strong,
how can you be when you're 50?
The conversation changes a little bit for me.
It's not,
you know,
can I dead lift 600 anymore?
It's,
you know,
what's this look like when I run an ultra?
What's this look like?
How effective and I am at running a 10 K or paddling.
Those are for me starting to be more interesting conversations and just absolute
strength or absolute work power.
How can I,
how does this make me a better mountain biker?
If there were any,
uh,
any sort of parting tips,
suggestions,
requests that you could make of the people out there who either currently
crossfitting or considering crossfitting well,
what would you say to them?
What would you suggest?
Tooth.
It's not about who can work hardest anymore.
That ship has sailed.
If you're in an a series strength conditioning program,
you are very fit.
You know,
probably fitnesses not unless you're a beginner.
Fitness is not the limiting factor anymore.
Your positional quality,
add intensity is the limiting factor because you're going to do the same
experiment that everyone has done and you will end up in a little tiny box at
some point wondering why you're George Saint Pierre and you've torn both your
acs,
right?
No one was fitter.
No one was more powerful,
but as positions,
costume is acs and now he's that consciousness has come at a very,
very high price and you know you should be able to do these things forever.
You know there's,
there's not a time where you don't need to get up off the ground or do a pushup,
but just thus become more sophisticated.
Let's advance the conversation a little bit.
Don't be a Douche bag.
If I walk into the room and you're rounding your back,
I'm going to cock punch you.
Come on.
It may happen once in a while.
Your heaviest loads.
I was drinking coffee and you've tried to cock much Jeff.
That was aggressive.
Luckily.
I know,
I just,
I think that's,
that's the issue is that it's,
you know,
you need to bring the awareness that we're supposed to bring to this.
If we're doing a five rep,
we're just not even a fiber at Max,
but were just squatting.
That fits.
Fifth Rep should look fucking good.
You just had four more like make it look better.
Okay.
We got,
we got to run guys.
Uh,
last question.
Any lesser known strength coaches or coaches period that,
uh,
that you particularly,
that stick out in your mind that people might
want to look up and learn more about?
More about?
Joda Franco is amazing.
If you haven't ever listened to Pavle talk,
you know,
he solved a lot of this a long time ago.
Yeah.
Um,
the,
the internet is rich right now with,
you know,
I would say,
look at who's been on the podcasts.
There've been some serious banner carriers for a long time.
Mark for Stagen at Exos has been talking about these basic shapes and comparable
positions for a long time who were on his show,
who's around,
you know?
Right.
Um,
and I,
and I think the working coach pieces is it,
there are a lot of models,
you know,
we just just need to start a practice and then from there we can advance
ourselves.
But there's,
there's a lot of really good thinking in the world right now.
It's very exciting.
This is a good time to be in the world.
Definitely.
So Yeah,
questioning your assumptions folks.
Test your own rules and don't be afraid to suck,
suck for the SOC.
Find a place where you can suck privately,
safely.
Kelly,
where can people find,
uh,
find you on the Internet and elsewhere?
Uh,
I'm on your couch,
Tim Ferriss,
couch.com,
and to be confused with other cats on the internet.
Oh Dude,
we're at MobilityWOD and mobilitywod.com and a man.
I can't believe I've been doing this for 10 years.
That's a lot of pullups.
Yeah,
well to many more decades.
All right.
Thanks so much man.
Appreciate you.
This podcast is brought to you by Mizzen and main.
Don't worry about the spelling.
All you need to know is this.
I have organized my entire life around avoiding fancy shirts because you have to
iron them.
You sweat through them,
they smell really easily.
They're a pain in the ass.
Mizzen and main has given me the only shirt that I need.
And what I mean by that and Kelly Starr at loves these shirts as well,
is that you can trick people,
they look really fancy so you can take them out to nice dinners,
whatever,
but they're made from athletics,
sweat wicking material.
So you can throw this thing into your luggage in a heap or on your kitchen table
like I did recently and then pull it out,
throw it on with no ironing,
no steaming,
no nothing.
Walk out and you could probably wear this thing for a week straight or make it
your only dress shirt and take it on trips for weeks at a time.
Never wash it.
It will not smell.
You will not sweat through it.
You got to check these things out.
So go to four hour work week.com all spelled out,
four hour work week.com forward slash shirts and if you order one of their dress
shirts in the next week,
you will get a Henley shirt for free.
That's worth about 60 bucks.
So put them both in the cart.
Use the code Tim,
Tim and you will get the Henley shirt for free.
Check it out,
four hour workweek.com forward slash shirts and you'll see some of my favorite
gear including the one shirt that I've been traveling with.
The Tim Ferriss show is also brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is your one stop shop for anything.
Graphic design related.
You need a logo,
you need a website,
you need a business card or anything else.
You get an original design from designers around the world who submit drafts for
you to review.
You are happy or you get your money back.
And I have used 99 designs for book cover ideas for the four hour body,
which went to number one your times for banner ads,
and you can check out some of my actual competitions@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim you can also get a free $99 upgrade if you want to give it a
shot.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash tip.